You’re seriously
posting from campus?
I'm not worried.
It’s like you want
to get shut down.
[phones chiming]
Hey, Bayview.
School is back in session.
And you know what that means:
So am I.
This week,
I'll be taking down four of
Bayview’s biggest offenders.
Let's just say,
I've got enough
dirt to bury them.
Your obsession with other
people's lives is pathetic.
Nobody at the school would
get called out for anything
if it weren't for me.
[cough]
Simon?
[bang]
Jesus, he's allergic.
I don’t think he's breathing.
You want to help?
Detective Wheeler
has a couple questions.
Wasn't it an accident?
They think
one of us did it.
Without Simon, you
get to be valedictorian.
You're accusing me now?
I know them.
I don’t know you.
We need to work together now.
And why should we trust you?
So you guys have no secrets?
I've got too much on the line.
Tell them the truth.
It's not gonna
change anything.
Everybody here hated him.
But who also hated us?
What is a secret worth
literally killing for?
[phones chiming]